i spoke with chief gm brett vich
yesterday about the far more pressing
business issue relating to patrick
mahomes not a fifth year option but a
long-term contract
here is
my question vicha's answer on
the overall status of mahomes long-term
deal
are you getting any
agitation any frustration any sense from
mahomes side that they want to do it now
no no not at all but you know i'm
certainly
we know that we would like to get
something done um sooner than later and
i certainly know that they feel the same
way um you know you when you kind of go
through the last few few months here i
think we've all realized it's been a
crazy time for the whole country um so
with a crazy free agency period combined
with um a new never been done before
virtual draft um certainly in our early
dialogue dialogue with um you know pat
and his uh representatives we kind of
knew that once things settled down um
we'd be able to to open up dialogue and
and proceed but i mean look we all want
to get it done it'll take time like all
these big deals do but um
i guess the best thing to say mike is
you know
he'll be a kansas city chief for the
duration of his career and we feel
confident about that
so look that's all that fans really care
about is patrick mahomes going to be
part of the team or not but
the extent to which he's consuming
salary cap space chris is entirely
relevant
to what kind of help they can put around
him that's the balance and there's no
real deadline that's why i asked the
question about are they getting any
pressure to do it now because they could
sit on this for another year they could
run this all the way up to the franchise
tag deadline after five seasons for
mahomes this isn't like chris jones
situation who has a clear deadline of
july 15 with the franchise tag applied
to him to get a long-term deal done or
not for the duration of the 2020 season
there isn't that hard deadline and i i
think that
to the extent that the chiefs can buy
their time
or buy their time as the case may be i
think they should
if mahomes isn't clamoring for a new
deal why push it why rush it why do it
in this climate why not let the world
settle down a little bit and then get my
homes taken care of chris yeah yeah i
mean mike i i would think that's you
know
what both sides are actually thinking
right now i mean as we've seen patrick
mahomes he's a pretty realistic humble
superstar and i think he's got a pretty
good feel for the overall big picture as
far as knowing what the world is going
through right now and that there's a lot
of uncertainty he's probably not going
to get his contract anytime soon or at
least not until we know and have a
clearer plan of what coven 19 does to
the nfl football season but nonetheless
i mean if you're the kansas city chiefs
you don't want to let this linger too
long you know this is patrick mahomes
this is rare you know this is really
rare mike and i i was thinking about
this last night when i kind of saw this
on the rundown just you know when have
we ever had
the guy who's the best player in the
league by his third year in the league
second year as a starter like there's no
arguments everybody would say patrick
mahomes is the best player in football
and not even at the start of his prime
of his career that's to me the
interesting thing about this contract
just because you know you're gonna have
to plan he's going to blow the current
market out of the water because they got
a plan for the fact that he's not even
in his prime and three or four years
from now when he's still the best
quarterback in football it is going to
look like he's underpaid to a degree so
there's gonna have to be
some planning there to make up for that
and i don't know if that goes to the
salary cap percentage or whatever it is
but this certainly would be one of the
first guys i would ever think about that
would be worthy of taking a percentage
instead of just a standard number
well two things here first of all veach
and you can hear the entire interview
and see the entire interview at the pf
tpm podcast youtube.com nbc sports i've
posted the video at profootballtalk.com
20 minutes a lot of interesting stuff
from brett veach but when i asked him
about my homes at first he led with he's
the best player in the nfl so you know
usually when a gm or a coach says
something like that about a player who
has yet to sign a long-term contract i
cringe a little bit because you don't
want to heap superlatives when you have
to go to the bargaining table because it
gets used against you but in this case
there's no debate there's no discussion
it would be disrespectful for brett
veach to not call patrick mahomes the
best player in the nfl we all know it
and he found him he insisted on the
chiefs getting him so if anything it's a
badge of honor for brett veach that
mahomes is the best player in football
okay i'm sorry
i was just gonna say
you know just because of what i like can
you think of a player
like this in your history or since
you've been in the business to where you
go
oh he's clearly the best player
in the nfl his second year as a starter
in his third year in the league that's
to me you know maybe the i can only
think of dan marino really that's the
only guy that i thought of right dan
a guy who declared himself that early in
his career as one of the best if not the
best quarterbacks in the nfl it was a
different time then though there wasn't
true free agency there wasn't a
franchise tag there wasn't that formula
that pathway to ensuring that a guy got
his second contract he was at the mercy
of the team he was never going to be a
free agent he was just going to have to
take what the team gave him or not play
at all so this is different because here
we are two years as a starter he already
has the window open for a second
contract and the question is when will
they get it done you mentioned salary
cap percentage and
that's something i've been pushing for
years now darrell rivas tried to get it
back in 2010 from the jets kirk cousins
tried to get it others have tried no one
has gotten it the teams don't want to do
it the league doesn't want them to do it
for whatever reason i think it makes
sense because it protects the player
against the ongoing spikes in the salary
cap and i think the team should embrace
it because it gives them certainty as to
how much of the salary cap is going to
be devoted to that player and you avoid
a situation where the player wakes up
one day several years into his contract
and he's upset because in comparison to
the market he's underpaid because the
the cap keeps going up and up and up
but given where we are right now chris
given the
the possibility
slash likelihood that the nfl season
will proceed if it proceeds at all
without fans in the stands for most if
not all of the games we are looking at
for the first time ever
a reduction in the salary cap from this
year to next year
and that has to be factored into this
analysis and maybe maybe the teams all
of a sudden
are inclined to go percentage because if
the cap goes down
25 30 percent one of the items on my
list to find out is how much money the
nfl was going to lose relative to the tv
money if it doesn't have ticket sales i
mean you know you can't have for example
they're not going to have minor league
baseball this year because it's not like
minor league baseball has a tv contract
that can prop it up if you don't have
people showing up for the games there's
no money to be made for football the tv
money is a huge piece of it bigger than
how much they get at the box office but
you know that take that out of the
equation
and and your cap is going to go down and
that's got to be a factor however you
structure it for patrick holmes that's
got to be a factor in what the chiefs
and mahomes do because you don't want
him to have
you know a 25 million dollar 30 million
dollar cap number next year if the cap
gets cut in half and it's down to 100
million dollars or let's say it's 120 or
130 whatever the case may be this is
part of the equation for anyone who's
doing a contract now but especially big
contracts
yeah
no no doubt about it i mean yes i mean i
think that's what if you're patrick
mahomes i mean i guess i posed the
question to you yeah would you even want
to do a contract right now in this
current environment you're right i mean
it's more beneficial maybe to the teams
to get it done and maybe they would want
to do the the percentage of the salary
cap but yeah if i'm a patrick my home
superstar in this current environment
right now i'm not so sure
you know i'm calling kansas city chiefs
and asking for a new contract uh you
know maybe
because there is too many too much
uncertainty and you want to see where
this goes throughout this year you know
patrick mahomes you know if you're
patrick mahomes and i'm in his shoes i
don't want to sign a contract where i'm
getting 40 and 42 million dollars a year
and then to find out like you're saying
in the 20 20 21 season
all of a sudden the salary cap is 140
million dollars and you're sitting there
going whoa i'm taking up like you know
one-third of this out you know the
salary cap or you know a little less
than that but either way i would be i
would have some trepidation if i'm a
player too because i wouldn't want to
ruin the football team from that aspect
next year because of my big new contract
and one of the things to remember about
this too because mahomes has said
multiple times that he doesn't want to
keep the chiefs from having a
competitive team around him
every year you get those draft picks who
come in at much lower salaries and
that's where the obligation is on the
chiefs to hit on those picks to
supplement the roster around pacquiao
homes but mahomes hasn't said anything
to suggest he is going to take that hey
it's my job to get paid it's your job to
manage the salary cap approach that
we've seen other players take and
there's nothing wrong with the player
taking that chris from my perspective
when you consider the risks they take
the sacrifices they make the value they
bring to the table i believe that nfl
players should always get every last
penny and when you have a special talent
like patrick mahomes who elevates the
entire league there's nothing wrong with
saying i always want to be the highest
paid player in the nfl maybe that's the
clause you put into his contract that no
matter what his contract will always
escalate to exceed the cap number of the
highest paid player in the nfl if he
doesn't already have that i think he
deserves that i think you should want
that and this is where we circle back to
what
brett veach said this is how you can use
it against him depending upon what kind
of hardball you're going to play at the
bargaining table you can say hey you've
said he's the best player we all know
he's the best player why not agree to a
clause to ensure he's always going to be
the highest paid player whoever the
highest paid player is whatever the
climate is he should be making a dollar
more than that person what's wrong with
agreeing to that
well yeah i have no problem with that
you know i just think there should
probably have to be a certain time frame
in the contract there right where it's
like okay maybe you know if we sign them
to an eight-year deal maybe years one
through five kansas city can protect
themselves to be okay you're always
gonna be the highest paid quarterback in
the nfl i think once you get past that
though you can't just say oh hey yeah
five years from now six years from now
patrick mahomes will still definitely be
the best quarterback in football there's
good chance we know that certainly um
but but i i i would you know i think you
got to be a little careful there and
then to the other thing mike i mean yeah
i'm all about the players getting
maximizing what they can get i mean you
only got one chance you know everybody
else their professions they don't have a
short shelf life like the nfl does and
when you're in the nfl and i'm the
perfect example injury can strike you
know i got a free i got tendered my year
i lost my spleen i probably could have
held out and asked for more money we
went to the we went to the playoffs the
year before but i went ah i'll be a team
guy and come back and make everybody
happy well you know what that did it
screwed myself over and you know that
was stupid business on my part and you
got to protect yourselves in that
fashion if you're an nfl football player
today
and see mahomes has the luxury of the
marketing money that he's now making
like probably no one else in the league
and he'll continue to do that that gives
him some insurance against having
something like that happen and he likely
has a gigantic insurance policy at this
point so might be my vine one way or the
other right i was gonna say two like the
other thing you know i think you're on
to something but like you have to be the
highest paid quarterback or maybe you
have to be the top three uh at your
position something like that i mean i
you know hey college coaches have that
right you know i know when i was at
texas mac brown had a clause in his
contract that he always had to be one of
the top five highest paid coaches uh in
college football you know i know i think
nick saban and there's some other guys
that have similar aspects to their
contracts too to where they're never you
know less than the market value for the
top coach out there so i do think that's
an interesting angle you brought up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports